vous avez tourné note de notre spectacle
dans notre émission de radio le
rock'n'roll circus tour ça s'appelait on
est en banlieue et un jour est arrivé au
fin fond de la salle était pleine
un homme avec une casquette new york
très élégant c'était jean luc delarue
qui c'est mais au fond et que vous à
regarder faire les cons et à la fin une
nouvelle et des bons je cherche de deux
comiques pour mon émission de rentrée
est ce que ça vous dit on à du bar à
réfléchir
et puis a faibli au prix qu'on travaille
mais c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
vraiment comme comme dans les films
voilà un type qui va vous repérer les
devoirs libéral ou derrière on a discuté
ave une bière on a senti tout de suite
il était utile et et qu'il était cool
quoi donc
et c'est comme ça que la france entière
a découvert qu'elle n'oublie pas qu'on
ait pu être la grosse tête par yves 48
ans n'a qu'un but mais sans convaincre
on a eu pas en pro b mais c'est
tellement tellement d'agde et quand vous
êtes reconnu dans la rue fusey faisait
le reste on vous reconnaît tout devient
l'amour n'est pas votre nom et je me
rappelle il y avait je me répète je
marchais dans les rues de cassis et avec
un groupe de jeunes brillants qui te
regarde c'est le fou de la deux mais ça
le fou de l'a21 absolument à première
fois voire inconnus
[Musique]
moi je faisais le cisr demeure et
qu'elle faisait 9h 12h et on serait
passé le micro là tous les jours à 9h30
sa plume à 30 secondes qui a plein de
milieux qui après un quart d'heure puis
après 20 minutes est vraiment vous
animez au lieu de faire des passations
micro de 20 minutes fait l'émission
ensemble
vous avez l'air d'avoir le même humour
de bien vous entend et donc il nous a
donné 6 9 à tous les deux et donc là on
a créé cet univers complètement dingue
du rock and roll circus ses troupes de
cette discussion qu'on a eue et ça me
souviens très bien c'était à vous les
faire en disant [ __ ] ça serait cool en
déconnant 15 gens iront affronter l'un
jean infime mais quand tu rencontres
réalisera est toujours à blanc ça
c'était en 92 donc c'est un truc à 982
impôts nouvelles doléances à l'époque
madame winehouse comme amis s'arrêtant à
12 donc c'est autre chose la peste
allied est encore la laiterie la
chaumière chunyan garde c'est une
maladie grave ce salaire en gt pied pour
le flou de ce cas être qu'on devait
écrire en cause et l'émission qui a duré
trois heures tous les matins trois
heures de sketches interview de fausses
interviews de faux chanteurs et parmi
toutes les séries il convenait beaucoup
de scènes feuilleton et des vieux
feuilletons français feuilles tombent
ceci fait tomber dicko fait-on on a tous
fait un jour on est tombé sur ces 2 et
de reflets que par hasard on a écrit
c'est bon en impro totale on était en
impro à la radio on est et on écrivait
très peu et on a créé reaper et beliet
comme ça je sais même plus les noms
comment ils sont sortis ces vieux ça
fait un seul vol et était fan du film
dresse était fan de harry potter je
crois que ça vient de la cinquième en
principe les acteurs jack et on l'avait
ans s'était donné ces noms là on s'était
donné ces personnes étaient là on a ça
s'est fait tellement facilement puis
après c'était facile puisque à l'époque
et encore aujourd'hui c'est vu que dans
des clichés des films américains
allaient les belles voitures les grandes
villes le bruit les les toutous ce qui
représente le cinéma mais qu'un hésité
pour les gens un peu laissé départ au
vieux cons
[Musique]